bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on s es et on
va parler du nouveau téléphone un des
nouveaux téléphones de honor le honor 7x
maintenant
[Musique]
honor celtics un nouveau téléphone de
chez au nord qui a l'air d'être un cas
tout d'un grand en tout cas sur tous les
grands surtout l'écran on a un très très
grand écran 5,13 pouces c'est du lcd
c'est vrai que on a vraiment une
sensation d'immersion sur cet écran il
est très jolie à première vue c'est vrai
que ça un écran qui est très sympa alors
là je le regarde en direct avant que
excusez moi
écran plutôt de bonne qualité ratio 18/9
un design plutôt sympa avec un dos en
métal dassier le modèle bleu des bords
légèrement incurvé en foulant bas le
logo au nord la caméra en eau en a -
version premium par rapport au vieux 10
le view dit ça quand même un côté quand
même beaucoup plus premium par rapport
aux 7 x mais bon c'est pas le même
produit donc on va pas lui en vouloir
à l'arrière on trouve le capteur
d'empreintes digitales et est situé ici
plutôt bien situé le double caméra ici
16 mégapixels et une 2 mégapixels 2
mégapixels mégapixels
vous avez une résolution fhd plus 2160
par 1080 pixels
c'est un téléphone sur lequel avec un
grand écran comme ça il va faire du
split screen peut effectivement profiter
de vidéos en immersion complète avec un
double caméra arrière
voir le portrait mode la 2 mégapixels
vous servira à régenter de la profondeur
on va pas chercher forcément de la
qualité dessus il est vraiment à vous
apporter cette profondeur nécessaire
pour sortir le mode portrait bien
évidemment
alizée recèle fille avec une bonne
sieste et reconnaît votre main il prend
la photo ça c'est pratique lorsque vous
êtes à distance ça vous évite forcément
toujours appuyé sur le bouton
il ya un côté un peu sympa cette
utilisation à l'intérieur vous avez un
processeur kirin 659 4 gigas de ram 64
giga de stockage qu'effectivement vous
devrez monter avec une carte micro sd à
l'intérieur côté batterie vous avez une
3340 milliampères l'heure vous avez une
surcouche le mi5 foie rein qui trompe
sur un android 7.0 voilà un peu ce que
perd que 10 ans se produira
effectivement compliqué de se rendre
compte à première vue dans un salon
comme ça si le produit est bien volturi
non après tout en connaissant les
produits au nord je pense que c'est un
produit qui est très bien débuté chez au
nord s'en veut plus de qualité 120
produits plus d'exception il faut aller
sur le au nord du 10e au nord sceptiques
sera parfait pour un premier smartphone
de chez honor qui à mon avis il sera
vraiment le job
surtout vu le prix il est pas
particulièrement cher alors me le
demandez plus prix je n'ai pas sous la
main je vous invite à retrouver voire la
précédente vidéo vous vous présentez ya
le prix et c'est comme ça moi vous
saurez tout la jeunesse la caméra à
l'arrière
c'est vrai que c'est
[Musique]
alors je sais pas si c'est la résolution
de l'écran mais la caméra caméra à
l'arrière
il n'y a pas un rendu génial
je sais pas si ça vient effectivement la
caméra de celle fille
ça fait un espèce de flou qui fait pas
naturel voiliers sont en effet bloqués
c'est ça qui est un peu bizarre
sinon bon après paul trille ses parents
il faut pas lui demander la lune mais
bon voilà c'est un bon smartphone de
chez au nord que je peux
pour commander si vous voulez rentrer
chez honor commencé dans la gamme à mon
avis c'est pas mal ci-après vous avez un
peu plus d'argent à l'est sur le north
gulbis
c'est mon avis le smartphone qui vous
rendra le plus heureux dites moi ce que
vous en pensez en commentaire est ce que
ces smartphones de au nord pourraient
vous intéresser
est ce que vous pourriez vous laisser
tenter par le au nord 7 x vous ne
marquez tout sans commentaire vous
invite à me laisser des jolies pouzin
vous abonner parce qu'on aura encore
plein de nouveautés sur la high-tech
chaussée aurait dû profiter on va les
voir énormément de choses je vous dis à
très bientôt soyez sages rendez vous
bien ciao